und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend wenn nicht mal mehr bestellter
jubel funktioniert weil die vermeintlich
gehorsamen nicht mitspielen wird es
selbst für diktatoren hängen das mag
auch alexander lukaschenko langsam
schwanen seine versuche machtvolle
unterstützer demonstrationen zu
organisieren scheitern und nun streiken
auch noch arbeiter in den
staatsbetrieben der ex sowjet republik
als lukaschenko heute früh ein
traktorenwerk besuchte schallte ihm ein
vielstimmiges hau ab entgegen
[Musik]
doch ob sie den diktator tatsächlich los
werden ist noch nicht ausgemacht
oder was danach kommt die eu hat für
mittwoch einen sondergipfel einberufen
doch wichtiger als die sicht der
europäer ist für lukaschenko welche
entscheidungen moskau trifft es sind
jedenfalls dramatische tage in belarus
berichtet christian sehr präsident
lukaschenko von den arbeitern der
traktorenfabrik von der bühne gejagt
doch damit nicht genug
erschieß dich offizier ruft ein arbeiter
lukaschenko noch zu nach dieser
provokation verliert lukaschenko fast
die fassung
machen sie sich keine sorgen ich werde
sie nicht zusammen schlagen auch
wirklich das liegt nicht in meinem
interesse wenn jemand hier etwas
provozieren sollte werden wir das auf
harte weise regeln
darum sei ein mann ihr seid hier eine
menge und ich bin allein um das handy
runter der arbeiter wurde nach dem
besuch festgenommen früher war das hier
ein heimspiel für den präsidenten
arbeiter die im zu jubeln so war das
doch immer in 26 jahren
doch die einst treuen gefährten seiner
machtbasis wollen nicht mehr gehorchen
im russischen staatsfernsehen sieht der
besuch in der traktorenfabrik am mittag
hingegen so aus wie in sich lukaschenko
in der realität gerne gewünscht hätte
die arbeiter hören zu alles ruhig
doch auch bei den bislang treuen
staatlichen fernsehsendern die er als pr
maschinen für den präsidenten
funktionieren wächst plötzlich der mut
für echten journalismus auch hier
brechen sie mit dem bisherigen system
ich nehme heute nicht nur an dem streik
teil
ich werde auch meine kündigung
einreichen die zeit ist gekommen wo wir
journalisten gerade wir eine
entscheidung treffen müssen
ich habe gesehen dass man manchmal das
ein oder andere thema nicht anfassen
darf oder etwas korrigieren muss oder
informationen verdreht bis sie nicht
mehr der realität entsprechen arbeiter
journalisten ärzte lehrer der
landesweite protest kommt aus allen
gesellschaftlichen schichten
sie eint nicht eine bestimmte ideologie
sie folgen ihrem drang nach freiheit und
das dass lukaschenko system nach 26
jahren zu ende geht
wir fordern vor allem freiheit für die
politischen gefangenen sowie freie und
faire wahlen ihr schaudert das herz denn
wir alle waren zeugen davon wie unsere
kinder geschändet wurden wie sie
schikaniert und in gefängnisse gesteckt
wurden aus ihrem exil in litauen meldete
sich heute wieder die selbsterklärte
wahlsiegerin der präsidentschaftswahl
svetlana tier allofs kaya per
videobotschaft sie sei bereit als
nationale anführerin verantwortung zu
übernehmen und lukaschenko sprach heute
plötzlich auch noch über eine mögliche
verfassungsänderung auch das wort
neuwahlen fielen aber bislang hat
lukaschenko versucht die proteste mit
blutiger gewalt zu beenden
doch genau das hat den widerstand erst
richtig groß werden lassen
minsk am abend platz der unabhängigkeit
die proteste gehen weiter friedlich für
begann moskau lukaschenko spricht jetzt
plötzlich von verfassungsänderungen und
neue wahlen ist das ein nachgeben oder
eher eine finte also lukaschenko ist
überhaupt nicht konstant in seinen
aussagen das sieht man schon daran dass
es die gleiche veranstaltung war auf der
erst gesagt hat man müsse ihn schon
umbringen wenn man neuwahlen möchte und
kurz darauf dann eben dieses referendum
und neuwahlen ins spiel brachte ich
denke der alexander lukaschenko hat
keine strategie empfiehlt die antwort
auf diese protestbewegung die sich
dagegen informiert hat und selbst wenn
er ein referendum jetzt ansetzen würde
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass die
opposition sich damit zufriedengeben
würde
denn ein großer teil dieser
protestbewegung der richtet sich ja
gerade gegen die vergangenen
präsidentschaftswahlen
hunderttausende pilger russen haben das
gefühl uns in der festen überzeugung
dass ihnen die stimme geklaut wurde und
warum sollten diese menschen jetzt davon
ausgehen dass lukaschenko bei einem
möglichen referendum dann plötzlich fair
spielen würde wie ist eine einschätzung
wie moskau agieren würden im nächsten
der kreml lässt sich vielleicht
verständlicherweise da nicht wirklich in
die karten schauen
man kann ganz sicher davon ausgehen dass
hier in moskau niemandem daran gelegen
ist lukaschenko in einer protestbewegung
untergehen zu sehen
aus zwei gründen erstens würde das die
opposition hier in russland befeuern
womöglich zu neuer kraft verhelfen und
das könnte dann wiederum unbequem für
die machthaber im kreml werden und
zweitens müsste der kreml nicht mehr auf
lukaschenko volk wenn das jemand aus
reihen der opposition ist dann müsste
man große zweifel haben dass das ein so
treuer verbündeter für moskau ist wie
lukaschenko das eben bisher ist ein
militärisches eingreifen halte ich im
moment aus sicht des kremls auch nicht
für wahnsinnig attraktiv
das liegt daran dass es im moment noch
keine rechtfertigung mehr aktiv dafür
gibt und die kosten nicht nur
außenpolitisch doch sehr hoch sehr
wehren
es ist also eine verzwickte lage nicht
nur in belarus sondern auch hier in
moskau ein gefühl für diese analysen und
wir schauen nach deutschland ein corona
gipfel der kanzlerin mit allen
ministerpräsidenten und präsidentinnen
der länder das hat es lange nicht
gegeben ein solches treffen soll jetzt
aber wieder im gespräch seien
möglicherweise nächste woche
anlass sind die aktuellen zahlen die
seit wochen in eine unheilvolle richtung
zeigen nach oben und das auf breiter
flur das vom lka heute früh nur 561
neuinfektionen gelistet wurden ist die
typische wochenend verzögerungen bei den
behördlichen meldungen die an sonntagen
und montagen immer auftritt an den
wochentagen davor waren es jeweils über
1400 im kanzleramt wird nicht nur diese
entwicklung mit sorge beobachtet es soll
wohl auch darüber gesprochen werden ob
es weiterhin sinnvoll ist dass jedes
bundesland eigene pandemie- regeln
aufstellt claudia voland beginnt ihren
lagebericht mit der frage wo aktuell die
meisten neuinfektionen passieren und wer
sich ansteckt mallorca wegen der hohen
corona infektionszahlen in spanien gilt
die reisewarnung der bundesregierung
der sommer neigt sich für viele deutsche
geht die reise zu ende
rückflug nach hause die gefahr dabei
urlauber bringen das corona virus mit
nach deutschland
bei den neuinfektionen sind 31 prozent
reiserückkehrer
aus dem ausland das sind fast ein
drittel aller corona fälle hierzulande
an allen flughäfen wie hier in hannover
langenhagen wird getestet um zu
verhindern dass reisende das virus
unkontrolliert einschleppen und
ausbreiten
auch an den landesgrenzen können sich
reisende an autobahnraststätten testen
lassen
für rückkehrer aus risikogebieten ist
der test pflicht es sind auch die
reiserückkehrer aber eben nicht nur wir
haben auch starkes ausbruchsgeschehen
wieder in deutschland und zwar haben
fast flächendeckend auch in allen
kreisen und städten neuinfektionen das
hat zu tun natürlich mit den lockerungen
das war auch ein stück weit aber es hat
immer auch zu tun mit vor allem mancher
feierlichkeiten veranstaltungen wo man
gesellig wird 69 prozent der neu
infizierten steckten sich in deutschland
an
ein risiko partys ohne abstand große
gruppen ohne masken vor allem junge
leute wie hier in frankfurt im juli
wollen feiern und den sommer genießen
[Gelächter]
doch die jungen sind nicht sicher vor
ansteckung das durchschnittsalter der
infizierten sinkt an zwölfter april war
ein infizierter im schnitt 52 jahre alt
am 9 august nur noch 34 jahre und auch
bei den jüngeren gibt es schwere
verläufe und todesfälle
feiern sind nicht das größte problem
aber sie sind ein großes problem spart
völlig recht also sage immer die weitere
verbreitung des virus hängt immer an
wenigen die sehr viele anstecken und
dafür sind feiern da der ideale
gelegenheiten
somit sind feiern also nicht das einzige
aber ein besonders großes problem auch
restaurantbesuche ohne mindestabstand
etwa in berlin größere veranstaltungen
und familienfeiern sorgen für die
verbreitung des corona virus da wollen
wir bis zum ende der woche vor einer
möglichen konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin zu regeln kommen die
möglichst bundesweit gelten also die
korona maßnahmen sind ständig zu
überprüfen und die frage der familien
feiern wird eine dabei sein
noch unklar ist welche rolle die schulen
bei der ausbreitung spielen in drei
weiteren bundesländern hat heute der
regelunterricht nach den sommerferien
wieder begonnen
trotz steigender corona infektionszahlen
sollen schulen und kitas wenn
irgendmöglich geöffnet bleiben
um allen kindern bildung zu ermöglichen
debatte über das masken tragen an
schulen dürfte bei steigenden zahlen
auch weitergehen erst recht wenn sich
corona fälle an schulen häufen darüber
zu diskutieren was man schulkindern
zumuten will ist eine sache etwas ganz
anderes ist es wenn erwachsene finden
dass es von ihnen zu viel verlangt ist
sich im öffentlichen raum ein stück
papier oder stoff im mund und nase zu
wickeln
spaß macht das keine bei manchen
verweigern aber geht es nicht ums
lustprinzip sondern um ideologie und so
werden sogar ärzte gesucht sie damit
machen und falsche atteste ausstellen
ein neues pandemie phänomen über das ina
baltes berichtet in die praxis von guido
marx kommen sie jetzt häufiger patienten
die nach einem attest fragen weil sie
keine maske tragen können oder wollen
denn das attest eines mediziners ist der
einzige legale weg raus aus der masten
pflicht geregelt ist das in den corona
schutz verordnungen also ländersache
das kann in bayern durchaus anders
gehandhabt werden kann sich nordrhein
westfalen ja aber die medizinischen
kriterien sind ja vergleichbar
und ich muss sagen dass ich also so eine
befreiung also höchst selten aus stelle
weil befreiung und nach dem motto ich
will mich nicht drangsalieren lassen
gehen natürlich nicht eine befreiung
liegt also allein im ermessen des arztes
meist erfolgt sie bei schweren
atemwegsproblemen aber die nachfrage so
berichtet dr max nimmt zu in sachsen und
hessen veranlasst dass die ärztekammern
zu einem ungewöhnlichen schritt eine
öffentliche warnung an die
berufskollegen attest bitte nur bei
medizinischer indikation in hessen liegt
schon ein fall vor dem berufsgericht ein
arzt hatte atteste im internet angeboten
in dem fall des internets ist es ja so
dass das absolut unbekannte patienten
sind das heißt der hat oder die kollegen
die das machen haben den patienten weder
gesprochen noch gesehen das heißt es ist
ein absolutes gefälligkeit attest was
aus medizinischer sicht auch absolut
unwirksam ist gültiges attest oder nicht
das ist schwer zu bewerten
es gibt einige wenige ärzte die die
schutzmaßnahmen für unsinnig halten
sie haben sich unter anderem im verein
mediziner für gesundheit freiheit und
demokratie zusammengeschlossen
ein verein der provoziert und gegen die
korona maßnahmen angeht er ruft ärzte
dazu auf massenhaft atteste gegen die
masten pflicht auszustellen
deshalb meine inständige bitte an euch
alle liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
beteiligt euch so zahlreich wie nur
möglich an unsere aktion in dem auch ihr
euren patientinnen und patienten
anbietet zu prüfen ob er in ihrem
jeweiligen fall ein befreiungsakt
ausstellen könnte und eine liste derer
die befreiungshalle befürworten ist im
video angefügt es ist quasi die
aushebelung der masten pflicht eine
handhabe dagegen gibt es nicht und ist
politisch auch nicht gewollt
weil ich einfach glaube dass die ärzte
wirklich die allermeisten ärzte ich
würde sagen fast ausschließlich alle
ärzte mit diesen attesten gewissenhaft
umgehen sie haben mit dieser
bescheinigung ja eine gewisse macht aber
das ist auch gut so der arzt also die
entscheidende instanz in sachen maske
bisher jedenfalls sind deren befreiungs
atteste noch einzelfälle
einige alte weisheiten erweisen sich
dieser pandemie jedenfalls auch mal
wieder als war etwa dass man mit
menschen in krisensituationen neu
kennenlernen kann oder dass eine krise
vielfältige gelegenheiten bietet sich zu
bewähren oder zu scheitern
das gilt speziell für regierende die
entscheidungen treffen müssen an denen
sie später gemessen werden
aber auch die politische opposition
bietet einiges an anschauungsmaterial
das ist ein schwieriger balanceakt ist
politisch überhaupt noch wahrgenommen zu
werden ohne daneben zu greifen
die fdp ist dabei bislang nicht
sonderlich erfolgreich durch die
pandemie gekommen
und das lag nicht nur an corona die
probleme begannen weit davor jetzt soll
eine neue personalie helfen was dahinter
steckt erläutert ventil vor genau einem
jahr und vier monaten stellt christian
lindner seine antwort auf viele fdp
probleme vor linda teuteberg soll als
generalsekretär in empathie in die kalte
partei bringen frauen power in den
männer laden und nebenbei prozentpunkte
in den anstehenden ost wahlkämpfen immer
teuteberg ist eine politikerin die die
politische mitte besetzen will und
deshalb verbindet sie auf der einen
seite empathie und weltoffenheit das
eintreten für den frei sind und die
freiheit mit konsequenz und
rechtsstaatlichkeit auf der anderen
seite
heute ein jahr und vier monate später
hat die fdp neue fdp probleme und
christian lindner sagte seine
generalsekretärin ab die lage im land
hat sich verändert wie ich sagte also
ändern wir auch unsere aufstellung
unserer thematisches profil das auch
natürlich durch persönlichkeiten die in
spitzenfunktionen sind repräsentiert
wird frau teuteberg die eine sehr kluge
frau ist ausgesprochen argumentativ er
hat aber das war das große problem die
schärfe als generalsekretär in gefehlt
es war das muss man schlicht konzedieren
der falsche posten ist war damit aber
auch eine falsche wahl von christian
lindner und das feld in gewisser weise
auf ihn zurück er hat die falsche frau
für den falschen posten nominiert in
umfragen steckt die fdp im dauertief
gefährlich nahe an der
fünf-prozent-hürde
der hacker anschlag in thüringen hat
viel vertrauen zerschlagen und in der
korona krise dringen die liberalen nicht
durch die fdp ist nervös seit wochen
wird getuschelt ob und wann der
parteichef seine generalsekretärin
fallen lässt ja wir stecken in
deutschland mitten in einer tiefen
wirtschaftskrise und in einer solchen
situation haben die menschen null
verständnis wenn sich eine partei nur
mit sich selbst beschäftigt und deswegen
ist es gut dass die personaldiskussion
jetzt beendet ist auf dem nächsten
parteitag im september soll volker
wissing als heute merckx nachfolger
gewählt werden
wissing ist wirtschaftsminister in einer
rot gelb grünen regierung in rheinland
pfalz dort wird wie im bund im nächsten
jahr gewählt und wissing hat praktische
erfahrungen mit der ampel also
bündnissen zwischen spd grünen und fdp
ich habe dort jetzt regierungserfahrung
gesammelt und kenne auch meine beiden
koalitionspartner sehr gut und das ist
auch eine wichtige voraussetzung um
einschätzen zu können welche
möglichkeiten haben wir um uns
inhaltlich einzubringen eine
neubesetzung als befreiungsschlag doch
auch für die liberale one man show
lindner wird die luft
[Musik]
und jetzt macht erstmal heinz wagner mit
anderen nachrichten ist
bundesaußenminister maß war heute zu
einem überraschenden kurzbesuch in
libyen
er warnte vor einer neuen militärischen
eskalation dort maas sagte in der
hauptstadt tripolis herrsche derzeit
eine trügerische ruhe in dem
bürgerkriegsland
deutschland hatte mit der organisation
eines libyen gipfels im januar eine
wichtige vermittlerrolle übernommen der
bei dem gipfel vereinbarte stopp von
waffenlieferungen in das land wurde
bisher aber noch immer nicht umgesetzt
wegen der wirtschaftlichen folgen der
korona pandemie könnte die maximale
bezugsdauer für das kurzarbeitergeld von
einem auf zwei jahre verlängert werden
finanzminister olaf scholz hatte sich am
wochenende dafür ausgesprochen
heute sagt der regierungssprecher
seibert bundeskanzlerin merkel stehe
einer verlängerung grundsätzlich positiv
gegenüber die konkrete ausgestaltung
soll in einem koalitionsausschuss
beraten werden der ist für den 25
august angesetzt zur direkten
unterstützung von familien in der korona
zeit hatte die regierung einen
kinderbonus zugesagt von 300 euro pro
kind ab dem siebten september soll das
geld jetzt ausgezahlt werden in zwei
teilbeträgen bis oktober den bonus
erhält wer ein anrecht auf kindergeld
hat familien mit höheren einkommen
profitieren geringer oder gar nicht weil
ihn der bonus mit dem kinderfreibetrag
verrechnet wird
nordrhein westfalens innenminister
herbert reul hat nach einem umstrittenen
polizeieinsatz am samstagabend in der
düsseldorfer altstadt eine konsequente
aufklärung angekündigt auch er habe sich
erschrocken sagte reul heute über ein
kurzes video von dem einsatz das im
internet kursiert das zeigt wie zwei
polizeibeamte einen 15 jährigen am boden
festhalten und einer der beiden dabei
offenbar sein knie auf den kopf des
jugendlichen drückt die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt wegen
des verdachts auf körperverletzung im
amt der jugendliche soll die polizisten
zuvor angegriffen haben
erstmals sind in deutschland
kampfflugzeuge der israelischen
luftwaffe gelandet die sechs f 16
maschinen kamen am nachmittag auf den
nordrhein-westfälischen fliegerhorst
nörvenich an etwa 200 israelische armee
angehörige werden in den kommenden zwei
wochen an deutsch israelischen militär
übungen teilnehmen
es wird auch ein gemeinsames gedenken
geben so soll er das olympia attentat
von 1972 erinnert werden und auch ein
besuch der kz-gedenkstätte dachau ist
geplant
in den usa hat der parteitag der
demokraten begonnen wegen der korona
pandemie würde der weitgehend virtuell
statt bei der viertägigen veranstaltung
soll unter anderem joe biden offiziell
zum präsidentschaftskandidaten erklärt
werden zuvor hatte sich der 77-jährige
bei den innerparteilichen vorwahlen der
us-demokraten durchgesetzt bei der
präsidentschaftswahl am dritten november
tritt beiden dann gegen den republikaner
und amtsinhaber donald trump unzählige
kinder denen grausamste sexuelle gewalt
angetan wurde ein netzwerk von tausenden
verdächtigen quer durch die republik die
videos dieser kindes folter sehen
wollten und im mittelpunkt ein
hauptangeklagter aus bergisch gladbach
der dörfer auf sein eigenes kleines kind
immer wieder vergewaltigt haben soll
in diesem verbrechens komplex wird noch
lange ermittelt werden
rund 50 kinder konnten bislang entdeckt
und befreit werden viele andere sind
jedoch noch nicht identifiziert
der hauptangeklagte stand heute in köln
erstmals vor gericht
was immer am ende für ein urteil stehen
wird die betroffenen kinder haben schon
lebenslänglich für das trauma das sie
erlitten gibt es keine wiedergutmachung
und so wird mit andrea budde ihren
bericht nicht dem täter sondern der
perspektive von menschen die wissen was
es bedeutet wenn einem als kind eine
solche gewalt angetan wird
es quält sie bis heute maja der name ist
geändert viele jahre lang ist sie schwer
missbraucht worden für das was die täter
mit ihr gemacht haben schämt sie sich
unendlich
ich fühle mich ekelhaft ohne ende und
ich krieg das nicht weg weil ich mit
meinen händen mit meinem mund mit meinem
körper viel machen musste was ich
absolut nicht wollte und es klebt
irgendwie alles an mir schon im frühen
kindergartenalter begann ihr martyrium
ein familienangehöriger und ein freund
der familie missbrauchten und quälten
sie oft gemeinsam sie machten videos
vermittelten sie an anderen männern die
ermittler im fall bergisch gladbach
kennen dieses muster in den letzten zehn
monaten haben sie hunderte ähnlicher
fälle im netz gefunden das aufgespielte
material enthüllt unfassbares leid
teilweise vom babyalter ein schon
missbraucht werden und die kinder haben
aus ihrer sicht kein anderes leben
kennengelernt und für sie ist es normal
dass sie gebraucht werden normal ein
irritierendes wort für ein kinderleben
das von sexueller gewalt und folter
geprägt ist für kinder deren qual die
täter filmen und ins netz stellen
seit den skandalen von lüfte bergisch
gladbach und münster die auf tausende
täter und opfer verweisen scheint eines
klar wir alle kennen betroffene menschen
kinder jugendliche erwachsene ohne dass
wir es wissen
und das bedeutet im umkehrschluss wir
alle kennen täter und täterinnen die das
tun weil sexuelle gewalt im sozialen
nahfeld stattfindet eine million kinder
sind bundesweit laut schätzungen opfer
von sexuellem missbrauch in jeder
schulklasse sind schätzungsweise ein bis
zwei kinder betroffen
dafür dass etwas nicht stimmt gibt es
oft durchaus signale bei kindern sagt
maja auch in ihrem fall es gab viele
hämatome zwischen den beinen und im
genitalbereich ich hatte immer blaue
flecken über all das hat scheinbar
keinen wirklich gewundert
hinweise die stutzig machen doch die
wenigsten erwachsenen schauen genauer
hin oder fragen nach bloß niemand zu
unrecht verdächtigen
wenn ich mir sorgen mache um ein kind
das ich kenne um ein kind das ich
betreue um ein kind in meiner
nachbarschaft nehmen sie diese sorge
ernst und ihr erster schritt soll bitte
sein
beim hilfe telefon missbrauch anzurufen
um mit profis zu besprechen wie die
weiteren schritte aussehen können
menschen die sagen ich möchte da nicht
hingucken
das ist mir zu viel da haben die kein
recht zu ich wurde auch nie gefragt ob
ich das aushalte was da mit mir gemacht
wird
das wird gemacht und dann habe ich das
zu überleben
irgendwie hat man ja überlebt irgendwann
konnte sie sich aus den fängen der täter
befreien
mit intensiver therapeutischer
begleitung quält sie sich seitdem durch
jeden einzelnen tag ein lebenslanger
kampf der vielen der nun befreiten
kinder im fall bergisch gladbach wohl
auch bevorstehen dürfte zu diesem
bitteren themenkomplex haben die auf zdf
heute weitere berichte und informationen
zusammengestellt unter anderem finden
sich dort auch adressen an die sich
hilfesuchende wenden können und jetzt
nochmal ganz andere themen und meldungen
von 1 12 und da noch einmal zur corona
pandemie und den wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen speziell auf die
tourismusbranche auch mit blick auf
jüngste reise warnungen war der halle
wie reagieren die reiseanbieter auf die
aktuelle situation
sie reagieren ganz unterschiedlich die
lufthansa und condor fliegen spanien
weiter an ryan er hingegen streicht den
flugplan zusammen ja und die
reiseveranstalter sagen pauschalreisen
in risikogebiete ab bitter für urlauber
und die tourismusbranche die reisesaison
könnte schon viel früher als gedacht
vorüber sein
für mallorca ist die reisewarnung ein
schwerer schlag fast jeder job auf der
insel hängt vom tourismus ab viele
inhaber von lokalen note hotels fürchten
den wirtschaftlichen ruin bis ende mai
lagen die einnahmen nur 30.000 deutsche
pauschalurlauber sind gerade auf den
balearen unklar wieviele nun vorzeitig
abreisen
viele reiseanbieter geben ihren
urlaubern die wahl oft sind auch
umbuchungen möglich
anleger reagieren umgehen stoßen ihre
reise titel ab der gesamte sektor heute
stark unter druck
der deutsche reiseverband spricht von
einem herben rückschlag
reiseunternehmen hatten gerade begonnen
ihre verluste einzudämmen mittlerweile
aber fallen viele reiseziele wieder weg
der verband fordert daher mehr
staatliche krisenhilfe bei reisebüros
und veranstaltern droht eine
insolvenzwelle vielen dank zum sport zur
fußball-champions-league da steht für rb
leipzig morgen abend das bislang größte
spiel der noch jungen vereinsgeschichte
an
gegner im halbfinale ist paris st
germain mit dem deutschen trainer thomas
tuchel das finale der champions league
für rb leipzig und seinen trainer julian
nagelsmann zum greifen nah jetzt geht es
also ins halbfinale mit einem
überzeugenden sieg gegen atlético madrid
im rücken
obendrein die aussicht auf einen
gewaltigen image erfolgt eine weitere
deutsche mannschaft an der spitze der
königsklasse könnte einige kritiker
verstummen lassen
an motivation mangelt es nicht wir sind
stolz auf unsere dna wir sind stolz auf
unsere werte wir sind ein junger verein
wir sind neu das ist richtig es muss
aber auch erlaubt sein dass es mal was
neues gibt und dass wir keine 100 jahre
tradition haben das ist so das macht uns
auch gar nicht traurig wir schauen nach
vorne
heute schaut die mannschaft auch
portugiesische strand idylle noch einmal
durchatmen vor der begegnung morgen mit
dem starensemble von paris arrangement
den fußabdruck eines champions league
finalisten konnte wohl keiner mehr
ignorieren
das haus hat uns gleich nach dem wetter
gibt es im montagskino weiter und danach
um 23 45 gibt es die nächste heute
express bis morgen auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das tief ingrid
kennen wir schon länger das hat einige
unwetter gebracht und zieht auch in den
nächsten 24 stunden nur ganz allmählich
weiter nach osten
es wird die schwüle hitze aus dem
nordosten deutschlands vertreiben
heute nacht also gibt es gewitter
ungefähr zwischen nordfriesland und dem
bayerischen wald hinterlegen gewittern
lockern die wolken auf und es bildet
sich auch mal nebel
dort sinken die temperaturen auf
angenehme 15 bis 11 grad im nordosten
dagegen hält sich noch ein rest der
wärme mit 8 10 bis 16 grad morgen über
tag liegen die werte dann zwischen 21
grad am alpenrand und 26 grad am main
oder auch an der elbe und die gewitter
erreichen morgen den nordosten
das können unwetter seien also gewitter
die mit hagel platzregen und strom böden
verbunden sind im westen und auch im
süden zeigt sich häufig die sonne das
wird ein freundlicher tag bis dann
nachmittags zwischen dem hunsrück und im
allgäu sich neue regenschauer und
gewitter bild und die spannende frage
ist ja bleibt das jetzt bei diesem
wetter oder wird es vielleicht sogar
noch wärmer
das sehen wir beim blick auf diesen
vorschau film da sehen wenn ich das ein
neues tief herankommt und das schaufel
bis zum ende der woche neue wärme hier
von der iberischen halbinsel wieder in
unsere richtung allerdings kommt die
wärme nicht allein sondern es gibt auch
wieder gewitter noch nicht am mittwoch
da gibt's letzte gewitter in vorpommern
danach aber wird es deutlich heißer und
dann von nordwesten auch wieder
gewittriger schönen abend noch